[Music]
wow another adventure where I went up an
ass cliche yeah P Rick and Morty oh
great evil Morty's back which means I'll
have to do extra research to even
remember what was actually happening the
last time evil Morty made an
appearance an I patch you know how we
feel about Pirates budget Morty rental
Rick decides to be call back Rick so
show gives us a John Carpenter style
score and gives us a character with an
eye patch but said character is not
snake piskin man this show really hates
people enjoying spaghetti also it's both
odd and convenient that just about every
time a rick Andor Morty go to a
different world to encounter that Rick
and Morty they're sitting down at a
table eating together as a family do you
know how many families sit down for
every meal and eat together in 2023 I
mean I don't have the numbers in front
of me but if you said more than 1% I'd
call you a liar I'd have an easier time
believing the scribble in this article
is actual words if the headlines were in
actual scribbles Hy infinite families
don't invent the world's first three
different discount versions of the
Jetson and only two were mercifully
removed from their ankles leaving one to
experience the horrors of the place the
Event Horizon went this sequence in
whatever space this is just makes me
think of Candy Crush and much like the
game of Candy Crush that is precious
minutes if not hours that I will never
get back it's just good to see you
outside the sub basement even if you
never killed a version of yourself that
killed your wife backhanded compliments
merging Dimensions to consolidate my
decoys huh oh great Rick Prime is back
which means I'll have to do extra
research to even remember what was
actually happening the last time Prime
made an
appearance evil Morty should I grab the
net
yes oh with all the technology they're
using right now to find Rick Prime their
only contingency for evil Morty is a
net H they should probably get a sin for
being an absurdity within a Cavalcade of
the absurd but damn it the show is so
cute sometimes you're basically fracking
the central finite curve to flush out a
version of yourself evil Morty deciding
to be EXP position Morty shouldn't you
be turning yourself into a pickle evil
Morty deciding to be callback Morty at
least filter for probability stasis by
analyzing phasic Trends among your
distributive frequencies I've identified
this random science jargon being used to
prove that a character has seized the
intellectual High Ground dude literal
glass house I believe some of the stuff
in this room is probably some kind of
glass but this is noing house however
since I'm a nice guy if they're willing
to dedicate an entire episode to a story
line that ultimately proves this is in
fact a house I'll remove this sin
promise son of a you killed my
wife this ricocheting bullet somehow
doesn't hit anyone except the one person
with the personal force field and that
is some rioch shoting bullshet she's
also been erased from every Universe
across infinity and you might be
wondering why I'd rather hear how evil
Morty would be the one asking the
questions that TV sends all you have to
do is be the last Rick left does Rick
Prime not have his traps filter out
Morty because he doesn't care or is this
just shotty craftsmanship first it was
stagecraft being used during the
production of the Mandalorian then it
was the construction of the monstrosity
known as the MSG sphere and now we have
Ricks going all in on LED technology as
well when will it end you sucks at
eating so is sucking a bad thing her
tone suggested it was a bad thing but
maybe she was just being passionate you
know what I'm just going to make a note
to Circle back on this I took a heroic
step toward the portal title of my sex
tape
Jeff Bezos On Any Given Monday wow the
wife guy dead wife Rick considering Rick
Prime wiped Diane out from all realities
aren't a lot of the Ricks dead wife
Ricks at this point how does this
distinguish any one Rick from another
Uncle slow what the uncle slow wait is
slow movus actually family or is he
family in like a Dom tetto sense because
it feels like you're reconing him into
your genealogy just so to show doesn't
have to kill Jerry because we all know
Jerry was the only other
option since when can Uncle slow just
manifest his clocks like this he's
always just walking around with these
things out at family gatherings only now
after he's gone do we find out he had
this other power all along I guess you
could never really fully know someone
kind of the worst possible time to use
his powers just made the death happen
slower actually he died pretty instantly
once he hit the big ball thinging of
random energy Morty just because you
wouldn't use your powers to treasure
your last few seconds of existence
doesn't mean you can insult a
long-standing member of this family
giving yourself your own personal Bal
and not using it until just now this
Rick Prime is a real Basket Case even
for Rick the fact that he survives this
is very sinful Eli roths Rick and Morty
is it over is is he not exactly an alive
amount of blood said as if a rick needs
to be alive to survive
[Music]
something after six plus Seasons we yet
again have another example of a musical
Montage trying to make us feel things on
a show that spends 99% of its time
laughing in the face of anyone trying to
feel things this is like trying to over
your proverbial cake and sentimentally
eat it too people that think it's funny
to get sprayed with a water hose while
fully clothed thinking the comfort of
ant slow eventually finding happiness
amidst tragedy means we will forgive you
for taking our dear Uncle from us too
soon researching
researching zero
results so good once it hits your lips
it's so good I guy you are the man I've
glimpsed our future and all I can say is
go back now we can visit infinite
universes sounds like the worst vacation
ever and how are the horrors of the
infinite today
sir look Stewie get these stupid 80s
movie Robots out of here and leave me
alone son of a you killed my
wife Nice shooting Tex you sucks at
eating day tastes like paint so now I
can erase your whole family one by one
until you finally learn your lesson
nobody with the Jesus